you don't know how long have been
looking for you it goes actually now I'm
your girl off and you well you've been
dead long stop everything that happens
from this point forward in the Destiny
universe is nowhere near as exciting as
what came before it sure humans have to
push generic space battles out of the
solar system and sure the traveler is
going to get its light back eventually
but what's the best possible outcome
another peaceful Golden Age players
don't want coexistence they want to
shoot darkness and all its incarnations
with a black hammer right in the daddy
bags so here are five reasons the next
destiny should be a prequel number one
story the city age is where all the good
stuff happened humans are hunted down
and chased out of the wilderness to make
a last stand under the Hulk of the
traveler people build the city under
fire and then the Battle of Twilight gap
freaking destroys the entire outer city
Lord shacks our site 9940 Lord Saladin
of the iron banner they saved the city
and then for some reason start to hate
each other during the entire time the
human race is in real danger of being
wiped out and that's way more exciting
than the current plot of oh hey we're
good now take some planets back number
two faction wars the city age problems
didn't end with the Titans building
stronger walls and towers all the
factions had a huge mob war that only
ended when the speaker rolled in with a
Titan army and put the factions in their
place the truce was called the consensus
but I'm pretty sure it involved more
like aiming a feint bringer at
somebody's face and saying get along
factions meant more back then dead orbit
started secretly building a fleet out at
the reef in order to escape the solar
system new monarchy was trying to
wrestle power and the will of the people
away from the speaker future war cult
the oldest faction found a device in
Siberia that can actually tell the
future but scrambles human minds in the
process these factions could be morally
ambiguous and give the player a new
perspective on the universe and the
state of the human race number three an
uncertain enemy when destiny starts it
just kind of a flat out tells you the
vex high fallen in Kabal are a bunch of
dicks but if you read the grimoire
you'll realize they all rolled in at
different moments in history and all
have different objectives some led the
charge some have ambition well beyond
our galaxy
and some were just opportunists in the
late cdh Guardians had a Normandy
landing on the moon with no idea that
crota and his forces were there waiting
not only is that awesome wouldn't that
be awesome for you to be there and who
the hell is crota or even a Theon for
that matter how about a prequel with the
story of their rise to power number four
the history of weapons weapons and
weapon makers are epic this game is
about loot after all Soros is made by
the Hattori Hanzo of destiny y'all are
horn should literally have a holiday
based on its creation it's clear that
weapon makers have a huge impact on the
city and your character should try to
curry their favor directly rather than
from generic tower vendors who are the
people who make these weapons can you
even trust them as a matter of fact why
is everybody in destiny so damn
trustworthy a prequel could hammer all
this out and finally number five
character development your guardian goes
by your gamer handle and that should
tell you a lot but who were you before
you became Rob job 69 you freakin die
that's who you clearly were trying to
get out on the last shuttle and someone
slammed the Cosmodrome door in your face
even the people who escaped got murdered
at the reef and you also have this
entire life before that what was so
special about you that the traveler was
able to revive you and the backstory of
your character during the city age is so
much more interesting than your generic
mercenary life afterwards well those are
five reasons why the next destiny should
be a prequel in case I didn't already
spoil it for you at the end of this game
you would die now go forth generic
Guardian and kill crow to ten more times
on hard mode so you can reach your next
number that will probably lead to
another number which you will then carry
with you into the house of wolves well
beginnings our fight is far from over
you